i once asked merlin olson in an
interview the hardest he
ever hit a player what's the hardest hit
you ever gave one of the four horsemen
of the great
uh great defenders in the history of the
game
you know father murthy father murphy was
another
thing for him when he was done playing
but i asked merlin also once though
what's the hardest you ever hit somebody
he said he was in the la coliseum and
the browns came in and jim brown comes
around the end
and he had a clear shot at him and he
just unloaded on him
absolutely hit him into kingdom come and
he said he was going to get up and
have a whole he had visions of his after
he hit him he's going to get up
and he was going to watch jim jim
brown's eyes rolling in the back of his
head that's how hard he hit him
he said he got up and he watched jim
brown run 80 more yards for the
touchdown
story of the hardest he ever hit a
player in his hall of fame career
wow the man who plays jim brown in this
uh brilliant film
that has got a ton of oscar buzz uh not
just because it's
uh the film feature directorial debut of
oscar winner one of our favorites regina
king but the
performances uh by the cast members and
the storytelling and all
of that the man who plays jim brown in
one night in miami which you can see on
amazon
prime video back here on the rich island
show all this hodge how are you all this
i'm fantastic how you doing brother i'm
better for talking to you i don't know
if you just heard the story i just told
about jim brown oh i did oh
i did right 80 more yards man
kept going superhuman well it's good to
be talking to you again man glad to be
back home
same to you and so one night in miami is
about uh the night of
february 25th 1964 when cassius clay
surprised sunny liston in miami um
and then and then uh it's based on the
award-winning play of the same name
uh that uh cassius went out um and
celebrated with
sam cook and malcolm x and jim brown and
you played jim brown in this how did you
approach this role
all this so the research that i started
doing initially was
i wanted to see who he was in the 60s in
this time this transitional period as he
was
about to make the leap from you know
football to
to film and i believe this would be his
last year
in football where we meet him in the
film but uh
i studied what his moves were in terms
of business
and economics and understanding where uh
he was at on the culture his views on
what was going on in society at the time
so i saw
i researched a lot of great interviews
uh speeches that he gave um
interviews i saw on youtube of them you
know um
there's a wealth of not i mean he's got
autobiographies he's got
you know like this there's so much work
that i could pull from but i just really
tried to
specify the 60s and a little bit into
the early 70s to get
where he was at this point in his life
well in in a handful of interviews that
i've done
um with him where he was the a i was the
cue in it
all this i did ask him once i'm like so
why did you just leave football
why did you leave football and honestly
one one of i've asked him this multiple
times but this is my favorite answer he
gave he goes
well you know i decided you know uh
i'm paraphrasing here he goes in
football you know you couldn't be
hanging out with raquel welch and people
saying here's your coat mr brown here's
your coffee mr brown
that did not happen when he was a member
of the cleveland browns that's basically
what he said
and i'm like okay i'm picking up what
you're putting down
jim brown i can see what you're saying i
can see
the benefits over there i got you right
it just but
did you learn about about uh how how
this one night in miami did
maybe go down and similar to what this
play was about and this
this film is about yeah so per
uh a brilliant writer kemp uh this
conversation
is sort of uh uh in a reimagination of
history right
taken from um different influential
moments but
the actual night did happen the events
of what occurred afterwards did happen
in terms of cassius clay
the next morning um coming out to the
world to say that he was a member of the
nation of islam
of course we know later that year we
would not have
sam cook or well within the year we
would not have sam cook
or brother malcolm x with us
and then jim did leave football and he
made his transition into
to film and then a few years later
started the black economic union
so it's it's i think a really
firm and and and foundational telling of
what the conversation might have been
you know based off of these men and
their ex-boys and the research done on
their relationships with one another
kim uh he has a background in journalism
and the man
knows stories he knows people and he's
done all the research and all the work
and he uh
he's really an incredible example of
how to take lives and exploits and
accomplishments and truly celebrate
what that is and what it's done for us
today what must it have been like right
that the night that cassius clay knocked
out sonny liston
oh man right and then imagine i mean and
and then jim brown
was calling the fight he was ringside
for it yeah
and then and then let's all go hang out
with us let's go let's go hang out with
uh let's go having a party with sam cook
right and and uh throw malcolm x and
malcolm x in for good measure i mean my
goodness what must that
have been like so so here's how i heard
it because uh and
that was actually one of the coolest
things to be able to hear jim brown
the actual recordings of him ringside
and what he was saying and how he was
saying it because when i did my ringside
thing you know
we we did it and we ad-libbed a couple
lines and we did a couple takes but
i was really just referencing how he was
in in you know during the real event but
as i heard it you know don't quote me
but yes as i heard it um there was no
big celebration really planned in cash's
honor because
there are a lot of people betting
against them they didn't expect him to
win right so
you know brother malcolm was like hey
[Music]
let's let's uh let's go to work because
um
i knew they had big plans of course uh
which is part of the reason why he's
down there but they they had big plans
for the announcement
and really discussing it and um i just
find it fascinating that these four
particular men
after this grand celebration chose to
get together this night
and really sit there and talk about
doing work you know what i'm saying you
just have this great celebration it's
like all right
now let's talk about the real work that
we got to keep doing
we we got this let's keep it pushing
forward it's it's really incredible to
me because
you don't really see that you know these
men it's like winning an oscar and then
going to instead of celebrate you get in
a room with your buddies and say all
right now
how can we keep making better movies and
creating better opportunities for people
that really need it like that's the
equivalent
you know what i mean aldous hodge here
on the rich eisen show one night in
miami you can see it
on uh amazon prime video right now
what in the world was it like she's one
of my favorite people on the planet
she's been on the show
she was uh years ago uh part of the nfl
network
fantasy football league as well she's
just a dynamite person and also just
great at everything she does what was it
like
being an actor in the film uh feature
film directorial debut of regina king
all this well i gotta say man that being
able to have the privilege of being in
her first feature film
is amazing you don't get a chance like
that ever that's a once in a lifetime
deal especially with the caliber of the
film that we're putting on but she
really is a brilliant director she knows
how to communicate with people she knows
how to
really get you to understand her vision
and and she kept tone
with this film because there were so
many beats that needed to connect
because of the way kemp wrote it so
strategically
all these moments connected and if they
were acted
improperly you're not going to get the
message but regina
knew how to keep us and keep keep that
tone going keep the rhythm right
um she understands how to navigate
through the problems that we
naturally go through on set with like
time constraints
and weather issues and she never loses
her cool but she has such a clear vision
she understands
the details the subtleties and every
little thing to really bring something
like this alive
uh man she really is i call her a
visionary savant
that's a good way to that's a good way
to put it how important was it for a
person of color to direct us
oh it was instrumental in every way
and necessary in every way because of
the meaning because of the message
and because of
there there's a there's an educational
wealth coming from one's culture that
cannot be
um implied that cannot be
uh uh falsified or or
uh idealized if one hasn't experienced
it right
so in this case the importance of these
four men is not just who they
are in their profession what they're
talking about it's their culture
it's why they do what they do i pay
attention to jim brown
not based off of his accolades as a as a
top tier athlete
with records unbroken today as as a top
actor you know i pay attention to what
motivated him to accomplish those great
things
and a lot of it had to do with his place
in the world and in dealing with
his culture right so having somebody at
the helm who understands the necessity
of celebrating and really understanding
what the conversation
is and why we need to have this
conversation when it comes to making
creative choices
especially on the fly her being black
meant everything to the success of this
film
well this is a pleasure having you on uh
just a couple of minutes left with you
uh you do realize now uh you've played
brian banks jim brown
and also voodoo tatum in friday night
lights you've
you've pretty hit pretty much almost
every level of football i don't know
what's next for you
yeah yeah you've done that uh when am i
seeing city on a hill again
what a dynamite first that was we
actually um
i believe ooh don't kill me on this
don't quote me but i believe we actually
debut
i believe march so it's insane it's in
the can then you have shot a second
season with kevin bacon oh yeah i'm
actually
on our last week of shooting as i as i
speak we are on our last week of filming
so we had a little setback with the
quarantine and we took a few months off
but uh we're back at it and you will see
a new season this year for certain
okay and uh also i don't know if you're
aware but
um you uh bruce willis and uh his wife
holly
i think are the only individuals to
appear in multiple die hard films
um you're in die hard with a vengeance
and a good day to die hard
i know i'm a little late with this
question but what the heck is die hard a
christmas movie is the original die hard
of christmas movie
the original die hard is absolutely a
christmas
movie irrefutable absolutely a christmas
movie
you sure it's not a movie that just took
place around christmas like you you
it is a christmas movie you it was a
christmas
movie the man went on a mission he
jingled all the way
[Laughter]
that's that's look it's a christmas
movie because i know around christmas
that is one of the top movies that
people love to watch and they play it
over and over and over
and because we gotta have a question
look the answer is yes
die hard with the original one die hard
one absolutely christmas
but i mean you know it's a wonderful
life place at christmas but but they
didn't blow the roof off the bank you
know what i'm saying like
i mean certain people celebrate
christmas different ways
you know saying like things are always
bad what's going on
you know okay all right all this um
we'll just agree to disagree
uh and uh with my my wife and i we
showed our three kids hidden figures
they loved it
they thought it was one of the best
movies they've ever seen so congrats on
on
all that and everything going on thank
congrats on this and no when city on a
hill comes back let's have you back on
to promote that and just chop it up some
more thank you
really appreciate it absolutely man i
appreciate you right back at you that's
aldis hodge check out one night in miami
and leslie odom my gosh leslie odom jr
is sam cook
everybody from hamilton knows the man
who played aaron burr sir
is dynamite my gosh what a
cast that is and everybody should check
it out hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here